so this admin Keyon
training uh you'll just work on your
[Music]
smoothness
smoo
this one it's going to require the
same Center engagement okay you can't
just try to
turn
same
this the same side
again there's two key points with there
all related to this
movement one this arm can't be stuck in
there cuz he's just going to pull it
picking
up
two your back mouth
defense is not just
here cuz he can still step over and un
jacked Okay so
it's
here these two things
okay
here here not here
here so I can't move away from the guy I
have to turn in
place here and my arm KN
there
okay let's
try same beginning same arm under I'm
going to do that same
exercise but this time I'm going to come
to this single leg
here okay so open it up a little I just
have this what
okay go
back my head is deep in his
hip CR open up a little here okay and
from here I shoulder pressure I'll reach
to
cap the other ankle okay this way and
I'm going to
drive
and
War
HP to
the in here not out here you get
choked other arm probably
better okay so in here try the choke
those space for his arm okay come around
cap
you don't have to pull it in you just
have to cap it thumb l cap
drive back step if you have
to and you're inside control one more
time
let's try this one's as he's coming
on this
angle so the guy would be passing he's
passing something and he's coming around
and I'm turn boom I have this push on me
and I get that okay but I I have my core
here
right so we'll just do it from his
assuming War right here on the jaw hinge
boom okay and he's going to he's going
to try to
push right that's what we do so when he
tries to push I move it out of the way
and I have my butter okay so do it
again so fit the
space open it up a little
my hooks are inside his thighs but I'm
not broken in my Center I have the same
thing I've been using okay
so once I get this
position come
around to
here
head get the overhook on this arm keep
that same lock
Center and on the diagonal bring him
with you
kick to
take so we go
back
this
Center this
part this part
Center
Center and this part Center okay
in CCH bring him with your
Center High
m
keep your Center engaged good so already
my my my core is engaged so if he turns
me over just don't do a technique just
turn me over see my whole body okay I'm
not here like this and he turns me over
and it kind of just slinks over my body
is engaged with my sens okay so when he
when he comes in the whole body
moves
[Music]
and then he's going to drive and I use
that to turn me you see that just by
being connected you could you could go
like this right you could do it manually
but we're working on core engagement so
when he goes to drive it turns me you
see keep your core engage he goes turns
you but I just
collaps so as my Center is
engaged Home Center engaged he goes I
don't collapse I go in even
more then my core is engaged so if if I
go
back no we're stuffed now so when I go
back he goes back so cor you see I keep
just changing this um Teter
totter
okay do you see how slow it could
be okay it's just a balancing game okay
go my my core is engaged in that same
way so your your tonden is not sitting
on the surface of your skin okay it's in
deeper and it's all the way around your
body so that's what we mean when I say
core I don't mean your abdominals okay I
mean your T in so I kind of call it a H
Band okay that whole H Band is engaged
it doesn't doesn't yield with hinges
that are naturally there with my spine
and my ribs okay
um so uh same thing on him he's doing
the same thing I'm doing the same so I'm
not here like that I'm doing I have the
same exact feeling okay same
feeling and he's going to have the same
[Music]
feeling same feeling don't go like this
same feeling lock
and he keeps the same feeling so he
doesn't start collapsing you see he
keeps that same feel
boom
Bo same feeling even now same feeling
just like inside control before he got
on me I was already
engaged meaning it was already activated
it's already pressured so same thing
before he comes in
active it stays
active
okay let's
go so uh this hotle
band is what is going to maintain
Integrity between my upper body and my
lower body which is necessary if I'm
going to take his energy and ground
Vector it and then have it come back
because if the energy comes into me in
this thing collapses and it doesn't go
into the ground it won't bounce back out
okay so I have to keep that structure as
I'm going and it's not that I'm yielding
out of the way this thing this turn
right here is moving him in you see that
so I'm not trying to not use it I'm
using it on this part okay and then he's
using it and I'm using it I don't start
going like this you see that difference
of boom lock and then I'm going to do
the body lock throw so this is the body
lock
throw in body
lock as opposed to he goes in and he
bends backwards for you that he had to
break his Center do you see
that people that are aggressive they
don't break their Center okay so I have
to have a guy that's strong and then I
learn how to do the body
locks okay try yeah